LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
dopé par la crise sanitaire la isenté
est en pleine explosion le numérique a
vraiment permis de révolutionner les
approches de prévention notamment en
permettant d'avoir quelque chose de
beaucoup plus personnalisé parfois
accusé de déshumaniser les soins le
numérique vient plutôt en soutien au
professionnel de santé
on laisse pas seul c'est pas que ça
remplace la consultation traditionnelle
classique cardiologique pas du tout au
cœur de cet enjeu les données qu'il faut
stocker sécuriser mais aussi mieux
collecter
vraiment important c'est d'avoir
suffisamment de données
alors comment prendre le virage du
numérique pour améliorer notre système
de santé la santé numérique
tiendra-t-elle ses promesses c'est le
thème de ce numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numérotat de santé on va parler
du numérique qui est déjà omniprésent
dans le quotidien de la santé on ne se
rend pas forcément compte mais le
potentiel est gigantesque bonjour
professeur teignel bonjour Elisabeth
Martichoux d'abord une définition laïc
santé qu'est-ce que c'est est-ce que par
exemple quand je télécharge sur mon
téléphone une application santé qui me
permet de mesurer mon activité physique
ou de voir quel est le rapport entre mon
poids et ma taille etc vous connaissez
ça par coeur est-ce que c'est déjà de la
santé numérique alors le numérique va
transformer profondément tous les
aspects de la santé avec des
applications avec des algorithmes à
partir de données qui sont générées ce
qui est important pour rester dans le
domaine de la santé c'est que c'est
utilisations numériques soient validées
que ce soit ce qu'on appelle des
dispositifs médicaux que ce soit des
applications et c'est la différence
qu'il y a entre les outils qu'on va
utiliser dans la santé et puis les
outils dans le bien-être donc faire
attention vous êtes si je puis dire un
peu le crack de de l'innovation
technologique et du numérique en santé
professeur ténia vous êtes directeur de
Paris santé campus vous êtes
anesthésiste de formation et on va
regarder tout de suite votre portrait on
se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
professeur d'anesthésie et animations
Antoine teignières et le directeur
général de Paris santé campus un tout
nouveau centre de recherche et
d'innovation autour du numérique en
santé passionné par l'entrepreneuriat et
le numérique ils fonde ilhumance en 2015
un laboratoire universitaire utilisant
des outils de simulation pour la
formation des futurs médecins
en 2016 il devient conseiller santé pour
le gouvernement puis conseillé covid-19
au plus fort de la crise
en avril 2021 Antoine teigneur a choisi
par le gouvernement pour prendre la
direction de Paris santé campus un
projet de campus de santé numérique qui
s'installera sur le site de l'ancienne
hôpital d'instruction des armées du Val
De Grasse et qui veut développer
l'innovation numérique autour des grands
enjeux de santé publique avec les
patients les professionnels de santé et
la société
est-ce que c'est en tout état de cause
une révolution pour le monde de la santé
numérique c'est une évolution qui va
amener dans certains domaines des
révolutions de fiabilité de faciliter ou
parfois de d'analyse que le cerveau
humain ou les capacités qu'on a
aujourd'hui ne pouvait pas faire et qui
vont vraiment passer dans une échelle
nouvelle avec l'utilisation de ces
outils numériques est-ce qu'on peut dire
professeur que le covid a été un
accélérateur de l'inclusion du numérique
dans nos vies et même au-delà dans tous
les domaines de la santé alors oui c'est
tout à fait juste il y avait une
dynamique qui était naissante depuis
quelques années auparavant la maturité
des outils était naissantes et surtout
les usages qu'on en faisait étaient
naissants le covid pour les raisons
qu'on connaît a été un accélérateur très
fort à la fois par exemple avec les
outils de télémédecine mais aussi sur la
constitution de base de données
spécifiques notamment par exemple le
système SIDEP qui a permis de d'analyser
tous les résultats de tests de PCR en
France quotidiennement et sur l'ensemble
du territoire c'est tout à fait inédit
et il y a beaucoup d'autres exemples
pour mesurer l'évolution l'explosion de
la santé en France regardez on se
retrouve après
[Musique]
le covid a donné un grand coup
d'accélérateur à la santé et c'est bien
parti pour durer même après les
confinements les Français sont restés
connectés à leur médecin le nombre de
téléconsultation est passé de 80 000 en
2019 à 9,4 millions en 2021 la licenceé
est en pleine explosion son potentiel
économique est estimé à 235 milliards
d'euros en 2023 c'est 160% de plus qu'en
2019 mais le développement du numérique
en santé est inégale il existe toujours
une fracture numérique 17% de la
population est touché par l’électronisme
elle n'utilise toujours pas internet
soit parce qu'elle n'y a pas accès soit
parce qu'elle ne sait pas utiliser les
outils de plus la isenté concerne
surtout les villes alors qu'elle
pourrait être un vecteur de lutte contre
les déserts médicaux cette
téléconsultation de médecine générale
sur 10 sont faites par patient des
grands pôles urbains alors généralisé
l'usage de la isenté c'est l'un des
grands objectifs du Ségur du numérique
en santé et du programme innovation
santé 2030 ainsi l'État a investi 2
milliards d'euros dans la santé
connectée et a lancé fin 2022 l'agence
de l'innovation en santé une structure
qui a pour vocation de coordonner la
recherche et l'innovation en santé
notamment dans le numérique
[Musique]
permettent de donner toutes les
garanties aux patients professionnels de
santé alors pour les patients évidemment
c'est un rapport tout à fait transformé
révolutionnaire avec la médecine est
d'abord avec son médecin je parlais de
téléconsultation on va regarder le
reportage si vous voulez bien d'Alexia
le péron oui il y a une autonomisation
des patients mais il y a certaines
limites aussi qu'on touche d'autres
après reportages
[Musique]
doctolib care médecin direct ou encore
Lifen l'utilisation des applications
santé a exploser depuis le covid 25% de
téléchargement plus entre 2019 et 2021
exemple avec vivoptim solution créé pour
les clients de mutuelle l'application
propose un accompagnement de santé en
ligne mais qui n'est pas uniquement
digital derrière l'écran se cache des
professionnels de santé bien réels
physiquement présent au siège de
l'application
allô je vous appelle pour une
consultation un bilan nutritionnel
Océane et diététicienne pour vivent
Optim solution aujourd'hui elle est
d'une patiente qui souhaite perdre du
poids je vais pas vous vous interdire de
manger ce petit carré de chocolat il n'y
a pas de souci par contre prenez le
temps de le déguster pour éviter d'avoir
envie d'en consommer un autre
c'est de pouvoir changer les
comportements améliorer leur santé
lorsqu'il y a un problème lorsqu'il y a
une pathologie et quand il y en a pas
c'est du coup limiter l'apparition d'une
pathologie potentielle
derrière cette vision il y a Virginie
femery directrice générale pour elle les
applications de e-santé ont transformé
la prise en charge des patients le
numérique a vraiment permis de
révolutionner les approches de
prévention notamment en permettant
d'avoir quelque chose de beaucoup plus
personnalisé et c'est notamment par le
biais de la donnée que les plateformes
numériques permettent de collecter et
qu'on peut ensuite traiter d'avoir ce
meilleur ciblage cette meilleure
personnalisation des approches grâce à
cette personnalisation certaines
applications permettent aussi de
surveiller la santé des patients
atteints de maladies chroniques
comme satellia une application de télé
suivi
parmi ces utilisateurs il y a Nicole
insuffisante cardiaque à 78 ans elle se
connecte régulièrement
ainsi tous les lundis c'est la même
routine
[Musique]
alors là c'était 45
600 ce matin
je crois
alors est-ce que je tousse pas du tout
je me sens pas essoufflé
les chevilles ne sont pas gonflés
je me sens pas du tout fatigué je valide
terminer
voilà ça me permet de
voir l'évolution de ma maladie
et de gérer un peu de se voir où j'en
suis quoi c'est rassurant parce que on
se sent
pas tout seul
mais pas de chance ce jour-là Nicole
réalise qu'elle vient de se tromper dans
l'une de ses réponses
[Musique]
et c'est 46 800 et 46 600
mais ça ça marche pas
contactez-nous et nous dise mais je sais
pas qui est-ce qu'il faut que je
contacte alors elle admet avec le
numérique il lui manque quand même un
peu de contact humain
dans les questions on demande répondre
presque par oui et pardon quoi ce savon
il y a pas de de dialogue possible quoi
c'est ça
pourtant il existe bien car ces réponses
sont envoyées à l'hôpital de bois Gibert
où elle est suivie
et ici il y a un professionnel chargé de
surveiller son état de santé à distance
dès qu'un patient communique des
réponses préoccupantes l'alerte est
donnée au cardiologue
par exemple pour ces patients qu'on voit
bien que la dernière semaine il a encore
assez élevé et son poids vraiment il est
déstabilisé là actuellement il a gagné 6
points 5 kg effectivement on prend
contact directement avec lui lui
expliquer lui poser des questions et lui
proposer modification effectivement de
répéter
son traitement en Suisse cardiaque on
laisse pas se le patient c'est pas que
ça remplace la consultation
traditionnelle classique cardiologique
pas du tout c'est que entre une
consultation cardiologique et la
prochaine que d'habitude c'est dans 3 à
6 mois même dans un an je le passage qui
sont vraiment stables entre ces temps là
le patient il est vraiment surveillé
si avec le numérique le patient devient
acteur de sa santé il y a donc toujours
une équipe médicale derrière lui la
Haute Autorité de Santé souligne les
bénéfices de ces outils sur la qualité
de vie des patients la télésurveillance
sera bientôt prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale
[Musique]
c'est évident la valeur ajoutée pour le
patient mais aussi il y a cette
accusation de déshumanisation qui a été
formulée dans le reportage elle existe
le risque existe ou pas alors le risque
il existe évidemment néanmoins cet outil
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'il va
permettre d'amener un élément
d'intermédiation entre le patient et son
et son professionnel de santé et surtout
c'est bien dit dans le reportage il va
permettre de faire ce qu'un
professionnel de santé ne faisait pas
auparavant c'est-à-dire suivre de façon
parfois plus riche quotidienne un
patient et pouvoir détecter plus
précocément des éventuels complications
des alertes etc et puis d'aller chercher
le patient ou de l'appeler quand on voit
qu'il y a des anomalies ce qu'on n'avait
pas forcément auparavant avec des
patients qui arrivaient aux urgences au
moment où il est vraiment il pouvait
plus rester à la maison etc est-ce que
c'est délirant professeur d'imaginer que
dans certains cabinets il y a demain des
médecins robots ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui et qui est très intéressant
et qui vous donne une une petite idée de
de vers là où on va c'est qu'il y a une
partie des consultations qui sont des
questions répétitives d'informations
standardisée que le patient peut faire
sans le professionnelle de santé c'est
ce qu'on a vu dans vos portes une
certaine façon absolument et donc une
partie de la consultation peut être
numérisée et automatisé et puis le
professionnel de santé quand il voit le
patient va avoir ces informations qui
seront recueillies et va pouvoir ensuite
dédier vraiment du temps pour d'autres
aspects notamment des aspects
relationnels ou des aspects de d'examen
cliniques et économiser du temps dans la
recherche des informations et puis
demain c'est l'outil qui va aller
chercher lui-même de l'information le
patient aura plus besoin de la rentrée
et qui veulent prendre
quelques outils qui permettent par
exemple de prendre les constantes
vitales à partir d'une caméra on peut
calculer la température on prend la
fréquence cardiaque en tout cas où la
pression artérielle
ce sont des outils qui sont là aussi du
domaine de la recherche mais qui
commencent à être utilisé pour le suivi
de maladies chroniques ce serait
évidemment formidable ça par exemple
absolument alors licenté c'est vous y
avez fait allusion évidemment tout à
l'heure l'intelligence artificielle
aussi en plein développement dans tout
les compartiments du jeu et dans la
santé pour la santé
Alexia le perron pour état de santé est
allé voir ce qui est fait en imagerie
cérébrale reportage
[Musique]
l'imaginait il y a peu encore prête à
remplacer les radiologues mais
aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle a été
reléguée au rôle d'assistant du médecin
dans ce service d'imagerie
l'intelligence artificielle a fait son
entrée en 2021 dans la prise en charge
des AVC
lorsqu’un patient est touché l'IRM
permet de voir quelle zone du cerveau
reste encore sauvage c'est là que
l'intelligence artificielle que l'on
surnomme l'IA intervient
vous voyez ici en vert toute la zone qui
n'est pas encore
un farci qui est la zone sauvable que
l'on appelle la zone de pénombre elle
est en souffrance
mais elle n'est pas encore perdue pour
le cerveau du patient ça veut dire que
si rien n'est fait et bien
l'ensemble du cerveau la partie rouge
qui est déjà perdue et la partie verte
qui est encore sauvage si rien n'est
fait d'un point de vue thérapeutique
toute cette portion ici verte sauvable
va se transformer en 24 heures environ
en partie rouge non sauvable ce que nous
apporte l'IA c'est la capacité de
répondre dans un temps très court à deux
questions
premièrement y a-t-il une zone à sauver
elle est visuelle il nous la montre ici
sans qu'on ait besoin de lancer les
post-traitement parfois complexes de la
perfusion et deuxièmement est-ce qu'on
est dans les critères de recommandation
en termes de volume pour le choix du
traitement
pour autant si l'intelligence
artificielle est capable de réaliser
certaines tâches plus rapidement on ne
peut pas compter uniquement sur elle car
elle peut se tromper
exemple avec un autre patient
cette fois on est toujours face à une
lésion qui est visible en séquence de
diffusion qui pourrait s'appréhender
comme un accident vasculaire
cérébraliste
et d'ailleurs lia va fonctionner dessus
comme si c'était un AVC ischémique or
dans le cas de cette patiente ce n'est
pas un AVC ischémique ça mime
cliniquement et en imagerie un AVC
ischémique c'est ce qu'on appelle un
strokmimix mais en fait c'est une autre
pathologie les IA n'ont jamais 100%
raison ça n'existe pas on utilise
vraiment l'IA comme une aide au
diagnostic mais une aide qui ne doit pas
remplacer l'expertise ni la connaissance
humaine sur laquelle est basé la
médecine depuis
des années pourquoi l'intelligence
artificielle peut-elle confondre des
pathologies que le médecin humain
reconnaît tout de suite les logiciels
d'intelligence artificielle sont basées
sur une technologie appelée diplorening
qui a connu un essor fulgurant dans les
années 2010
à la manière du cerveau humain la
machine va être capable d'apprendre par
elle-même pour cela l'algorithme est
formé à analyser des milliers d'images
de patients
à Paris c'est sur ce type d'algorithme
que travaille une équipe de l'Institut
du cerveau
menée par cette chercheuse il tente de
développer une intelligence artificielle
pour diagnostiquer des maladies
neurodégénératives
on veut faire en sorte qu'un algorithme
puisse différencier les images de sujets
sains
en disant ça c'est un sujet sain des
images de patients en lui disant ça
c'est l'image de quelqu'un qui a une
pathologie et au fur et à mesure
l'algorithme va être capable de faire la
différence entre des images de sujets
sains des images de passion et quand on
lui présentera l'image
d'un sujet inconnu il sera capable de
nous dire si c'est l'image d'un sujet
sain ou d'un patient
au cœur de cet apprentissage il y a donc
ces milliers d'images IRM de sujets ce
sont les données la clé de voûte de
l'intelligence artificielle
ce que vraiment important c'est d'avoir
suffisamment de données et de donner
représentatives
du cadre d'application si un algorithme
a été entraîné qu'avec
les images par exemple d'hommes
âgés de 60 ans en bonne santé ils ne
vont pas être capables d'avoir de bonnes
prédictions sur les images de femmes de
30 ans en mauvaise santé aujourd'hui
l'accès aux données est donc le pré
requis impératif pour la conception
d'intelligence artificielle performante
et fiable mais de nombreuses questions
éthiques et législatives entoure l'accès
aux bases de données de santé
ce qui peut rendre leur utilisation par
les chercheurs plus compliqués
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que l'application de
l'imagerie artificielle fait de plus
qu'une imagerie d'IRM de façon très
simple je peux vous dire par exemple que
l'oeil humain est capable de détecter 11
niveaux
de grippe puisque les images sont en
noir et blanc sur l'IRM alors que la
machine peut en détecter plus de 1000
donc c'est une analyse qui est beaucoup
plus précise deuxième c'est qu'elle peut
le faire plus rapidement
c'est immédiat et puis surtout c'est des
centaines et des centaines d'examens
qu'on va pouvoir analyser très
rapidement et donc plus c'est rapide
plus on intervient rapidement exactement
et dans le cerveau ou dans le coeur
quand on manque de d'oxygène comme ça et
bien le temps est un facteur clé pour
sauver les patients on a le même exemple
dans le cancer on est capable maintenant
de diagnostiquer l'origine de cancer qui
était auparavant d'origine indéterminée
et de patients qu'on va pouvoir traiter
avec des pronostics qui vont
profondément changer évidemment une
question majeure quand on parle de
numérique c'est le traitement des
données
tout ça vous l'avez dit c'est fondé sur
une grande quantité de données qu'on est
capable d'analyser avec des résultats
qui sont très positifs pour le patient
mais ces données sont les nôtres il y a
des barrières en particulier en France
jusqu'où doit-on aller dans l'analyse
des données dans finalement
l'utilisation des données qui dépendent
aussi du patient on a la capacité
aujourd'hui de générer de plus en plus
de données ce qui veut dire de pouvoir
ensuite analyser de plus en plus de
paramètres de fonctionnement à la fois
pour mieux comprendre notre état de
santé mais aussi avec la potentialité de
réutiliser ces données pour générer des
progrès comme l'intelligence
artificielle ou comme d'autres
algorithmes et donc ce qui est très
important aujourd'hui c'est de donner
les règles et le cadre de confiance pour
pouvoir utiliser de façon sécurisée ces
données garantir qu'elles vont être
destinées à améliorer le fonctionnement
du système de santé améliorer la
détection de certaines patholog etc
c'est un bien commun faire dans un cadre
souverain
si la question que vous avez souhaité
poser un parlementaire comme c'est la
règle dans cette émission comment
peut-on favoriser l'utilisation des
données de santé Philippe latton B est
député MoDem de Vendée il vous répond
[Musique]
pour ça il faut que on est un cadre
clair de conservation des données de
santé et d'utilisation des données de
santé à terme ça nécessite aussi de
protéger ses données de façon de façon
importante donc qui est une des couches
de cybersécurité qui soit suffisante
pour que nos concitoyens aient confiance
et soient en capacité de penser qu'elles
sont bien gardées et qu'elles sont
utilisées à bon escient et ensuite il
faudra expliquer pourquoi ce qu'on a
besoin de ces données et que c'est pas
simplement pour la personne tout de
suite mais ça peut être aussi pour des
recherches plus de plus long terme
voilà donc pour la réponse politique à
ce stade vous êtes vous favorable à quoi
alors je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
éléments importants le premier sur ce
sujet là c'est la confiance faire en
sorte qu'on puisse expliquer ce qu'on
fait avec les données le deuxième
élément c'est que on a besoin de ces
données pour pouvoir faire progresser
notre système de santé tous les autres
pays dans le monde ont commencé à
exploiter ces données c'est le cas
également en France simplement il faut
qu'on puisse aller à une vitesse
supérieure on n'est pas en retard parce
qu'on a une expertise médicale qui est
très forte qui est basée sur notre
héritage également simplement on voit
que on a besoin d'accéder plus
rapidement à ces données et développer
des grands entrepôts de données là aussi
dans des conditions sécurisées et puis
le troisième élément qui revient aux
questions de confiance également c'est
informer et éduquer sur la donnée
c'est un élément complexe mais il faut
bien que tout le monde comprenne que
aujourd'hui quand on utilise un
smartphone quand on utilise quand on
utilise des réseaux sociaux on va
sans forcément le savoir et sans
forcément avoir donné son consentement
envoyer beaucoup beaucoup de données à
des grandes entreprises étrangères qui
vont les utiliser et qui parfois vous
connaissent mieux que vous même merci
beaucoup professeur ténia on sait que
vous vous employez en tout cas merci
faire en sorte que tout soit accompagné
avec l'argent nécessaire si besoin merci
beaucoup merci et à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance vous
a présenté état de santé
[Musique]